The Mandelbrot set is a
perfect example
of how a simple rule
can produce incredible complexity.
At its core,
the set is generated by
iterating a quadratic equation,
a simple formula
whose highest exponent is two.
To iterate a quadratic equation,
choose a value for the variable.
Plug it into the function,
then take the output
and feed it back in again
and again.
The study of how recursive functions
like these change over time
is central to a field of math
called Complex Dynamical Systems.
This subject came about with the goal
of understanding the real world.
What are the mathematics
that underlie the physical world
that we see?
Most important early example
would have been the solar system.
So dynamical systems,
you have some space
where you have some rule
that's assigning,
as time moves on,
how that space evolves and
how things move and change
in that space.